spencer ackerman with danger room here
at AUSA and this thing strapped to my
head is the next generation of night
vision
it's the eyewear series manufactured by
ITT let's give it a shot for what this
thing can do so right now when you put
this display up against your eye you
don't just get the standard green night
vision that everyone's used to from TV
you also get this kind of ghostly white
effect and that's body heat
that's imagery that's projected onto the
night vision that everyone's familiar
with that shows where someone's you know
giving off a little bit of heat or where
if you were looking at a road perhaps
some dirt has been turned over and
that's useful for finding where perhaps
homemade bombs have been placed into a
road previous generations of night
vision couldn't do that you either had
your night vision gear on and you had
your thermal imager but you couldn't do
both simultaneously and this new night
vision gear you can do both you can also
do some other stuff there's a display
function to bring imagery from up above
on a drone some video or a camera
imagery perhaps on an aerostat or a
blimp down into the goggle so you can
see in exactly the same frame of sight
on the goggle not just what you're
looking at straight ahead but also this
imagery that we brought down from above
the thermal imagery and the video
imagery can't work at once but there are
functions that you can manipulate to get
one or the other in and so and also if
you go over a data connection like like
the army's jitters network through a
rifleman radio you plug this thing into
that Wi-Fi isn't quite available for it
yet but if you plug it into that you can
also send images that you are seeing
here out to other elements in a unit so
that's really a couple different
innovations that show where night vision
is going
[Music]